well they did it
I told you last Friday that the France was gonna vote to be the first country
in the world to make abortion a constitutional right
and they passed that vote Monday
if you remember
all this was sparked right after the Roe v
Wade was repelled here in America
Prime Minister Gabriel Adell said
above all we are sending a message to all women that your body belongs to you
with over 700 other lawmakers approval
only 72 of their lawmakers opposed this
in a special meeting
they even lit up the Eiffel Tower with the words
my body my choice
I believe this is a huge win for all women across the world
if you like having some good news stories in your feed
please consider giving me a like and a follow
it really helps me out a lot